here's what would happen if your tongue  was twice as long with a tongue this  long you might not be able to talk you'd  need to develop non-verbal communication  skills either texting or using sign  language with the extra space on your  extra large muscle you'd have more room  for Taste Buds and since you would taste  so much more every flavor bitter or  sweet might send you into sensory  overload  since you wouldn't be able to close your  mouth you wouldn't be able to chew  instead you'd need to get all your  nutrients through an IV or a blender and  with such a big tongue your mouth might  become a breeding ground for bacteria  your morning breath would last all day  long your colossal tongue would also get  in the way of your breathing causing you  to snore or wake up during the night  so although having a long tongue might  look cool I think I'll stick with this  little guy so